things change we moved to 8-bit
computers so we now have a whole extra
number at the start just to confuse
matters which means we can go to 256 we
can have twice as many characters IBM
compatible pcs came along and they
decided or what we're going to do is in
those high numbers above 128 what we're
going to do is we're gonna put many a
few accented characters that's kind of
useful maybe a pound sign in there might
be if you're in Breton maybe maybe not
some computers didn't and then we gonna
put lots of little lines and boxes so
you can draw you know nice little
interfaces and things that say hello and
then double lines and smiley faces and
wonderful things like that it's PC Mac
computers went oh well what we're gonna
do is going to put loads of accented
characters in and some nice
typographical symbols so you can mark up
the documents properly of course the two
won't talk to each other I mean while
loads of other countries are going oh
yeah okay yes screw you guys
we're do a set of our own systems an old
system like that has been programmed
well we'll take those nice curly quotes
that Microsoft Word has put into Unicode
and it will look at that and say that is
three separate characters from somewhere
above 128 in ASCII and all convert into
something that looks like that and
that's why that is why when you paste
those curly quotes into old systems
everything gets messed up it's because
somehow we have settled on a standard
and not everyone has caught up with it
yet and that's the beauty of it it more
or less works it hasn't messed up
everything it hasn't completely
destroyed everything we don't have that
motor barking that Japanese has we have
something that nearly works